it's weird the whole thing is weird this
is not a president of the United States
future hey guys I'm off the grid for
August but Donald Trump never takes any
time off and here's his latest
but that would make Kamala Harris the
candidate well not really I mean I guess
they'd have uh maybe a free-for-all a
lot of people say she has to remain for
certain reasons the candidate she has to
I don't think that's true actually I
don't think that other people would
stand for
she has some bad moments her moments are
almost as bad as his I think his or
Worse actually yeah but she seems pretty
senile too she speaks in uh in rhyme
and uh it's weird it's weird but she has
bad moments and in rhyme what do you
well the way she talks the bus will go
here and then the bus will go there
because that's what buses do and it's
weird the whole thing is weird this is
not a president of the United States
future
and uh uh I think they probably have
some kind of a primary and other people
will get involved I'm Newsome right I
mean it could be I mean you know I
always get along well with him believe
it or not but could be him could be
somebody else he's got a big a big load
on his shoulders because you look at
California what's happened
but I don't know if the American people
really the people that vote for them I
don't even know if they care you know
you look at so many of the things that
are
going on and people don't seem to be in
the old days if you had a bad record it
meant a lot today if you have a bad
record it doesn't really mean anything
you know he looks good he's a nice
looking guy speaks well
but Biden every time you watch him talk
and it's like he's walking on eggs
you're waiting for him to collapse
and he almost always does